Olha essa aqui que muita gente não sabe,
aquele cafezinho ou chá bem quentinho
que você toma logo que sai da chaleira
pode estar aumentando o seu risco de
câncer de esôfago. Pois é. E agora tem
um estudo britânico gigante comprovando
isso. Os pesquisadores acompanharam mais
de 450.000 pessoas por 11 anos e
descobriram que quem consome bebidas
muito quentes, quente pelando,
regularmente tem até cinco vezes mais
chance de desenvolver um tipo específico
de câncer de isôfago, principalmente
quem toma mais de quatro xícaras por
dia, daquelas bem escaldantes. Prestem
atenção aí, gaúchos, para isso daí. Olha
o chimarrão. Veja bem, o problema não é
o café o chá em si, é a temperatura.
Quando você toma líquido acima de 65º
com frequência você queima repetidamente
a mucosa do isôfago. Essa lesão térmica
constante gera inflamação crônica e aí o
tecido fica tentando se regenerar o
tempo todo. Nesse processo de
regeneração acelerada aumenta a chance
de erro do DNA nas células aí que pode
começar um câncer. Então, olha só a dica
simples. Depois que preparar sua bebida
quente, espera uns três ou 4 minutos
antes de tomar. Deixa mornar um
pouquinho. O seu isôfago vai agradecer.
M.